[Music]
thank you members as well very good
evening members members of the public
and those watching uh at home on YouTube
YouTube and welcome to this District
planning committee on Thursday the 2nd
of February 2023.
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I
am the chairman of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask you that when invited to speak
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise or as detailed as you
wish
Tara apologies for absence please
thank you chairman apologies can
received from councilors Bill boys Mrs
China Hill who bless games siddle
Stevens and stilts thank you thank you
very much indeed Tara
we move on to a gender item three which
is the minutes it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 1st
of December 2022 which is found on pages
of 7 to 14 of the agenda pack are
approved as a true and accurate record I
so move do I have a second for that
motion councilor Nunn thank you
members any comments to make on them the
minutes
agree these minutes by a cent great
thank you members
Declarations of Interest part four to to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-resistible interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
you're reminded that we'll also need to
disclose such an interest if you become
aware that you need to arise this
through the meeting members could have
do I have any Declarations of Interest
Tara looking around the room there are
no Declarations of interest thank you
we move on to the gender item five which
is the uh sorry cancel the stamp please
yeah
um I don't know if this is the right
time to actually speak but I do notice
that gender item six has been withdrawn
and I wanted to know if I could raise
I'd like an explanation please if
possible because I'm I'm really
struggling to understand what the
um reason was given it says photo gender
item six withdraw an item of the
committee there's a lot of words there
chairman but I I thought I was pretty
intelligent when it comes to planning on
some time so I haven't got a clue what
it means so could I actually ask for it
to be explained because I think I'm not
the only member here who doesn't
understand what it means before we start
the business of the rest of the thing
I'm taking care assistant I think what
I'd like to do if it's okay with you is
I'll proceed with the agenda as planned
but we'll hold that back until we get to
agenda item six and then we'll ask that
because then maybe other members who
have a question to supplement that if
that's okay
thank you very much indeed
um so we now move on to item number five
which is the report for reference two
two zero zero two eight nine resm
Reserve matters this land of Broad
Street Green Road Maple Road and
Langford Road haybridge Essex and this
is found on pages five to sorry my
apology in Pages 15 to 48 on your agenda
papers uh Mr Johnson is the officer here
welcome Mr Johnson who's going to
present the report
thank you chairman
foreign
thank you all right thank you this is a
reserved matters application for the
approval of access appearance
Landscaping layout and scale just to say
that those are the particular matters
that comprise the reserve matters but in
terms of the details the details are the
Strategic landscaping and infrastructure
for phases three four and five of the
approved planning application fifteen
zero zero four one nine
now the application comprises a number
of matters and it's just useful just to
go through
um what they are set out in The Proposal
the green corridors open space and
attenuation features within phases three
four and five and including those
surrounding Parcels three four five six
seven and nine it'll make a bit more
sense when I turn to the presentation
where I've set out some of these matters
just to show how they how they fit
together
uh the formal play areas including
locally equipped areas of play leaps
um to the north of parcel 4 and to the
east of parcel eight and a neighborhood
equipped area of play a neep and just a
bit of distinction between the those
those two acronyms the leaps are
basically for the smaller children and
the neeps are for the older children
the section of the internal spine road
which connects to both the spine Road
previously approved under Reserve
matters applications for phase one and
two and to the approved relief Road
including details of bus stops
uh the internal role to serve pass from
nine allotments and playing fields
pedestrian and cycle links falling
Within These phases including the public
rights of way
the location and layout of the plane
Fields South parcel 9 the location and
layout of the allotments together with
the associated Park in means of access
and enclosure
proposed pumping station
together with details pursuant to
conditions 18 which is tree protection
27 bus stops condition 28 foot paths and
cycle routes condition 29 vehicular
parking and condition 31 Landscaping
so
that's just the oops sorry that's just
the general
art down where the area is
um
there's a there's a there's a number of
slides that I've put in here to provide
some context because the application is
really about the the detailed matters
and the detailed method of which we've
um had PPA discussions around to drill
down into those details but also subject
to
um uh detailed assessments by The
Specialist consulties which are within
the
um the consultation section of of the
report so but I think it's what's really
important is just how the whole jigsaw
fits together because there's been quite
a number of applications which have come
through to members when you look in the
report you know there's quite a fair few
discharge of conditions applications
some of which wouldn't normally come to
to to the committee here but this is
just give an overview of how it all fits
and then where this particular
application is is is is within the whole
scheme of them
so you know throughout the various
reports you know we hear about the
phases so I thought it'd be just useful
just to set out
um these phrases the phasing which part
of the development comes um forward at a
particular time and how that relates to
other parts you hear it in in the
reports so just to show we've got phase
one over here
um phase two uh three through to phase
phases five
and within the phases we have the
various Parcels you've got the
residential Parcels Etc and again we
hear references to those
so so what sort of set out here is
within the various phases here you've
got Parcels one and two uh uh 10 11 and
12 etc etc so again
um it's again useful that's why with
your with with the presentation pack
sent to you it's useful to have that to
again put things into context when
applications come forward where in the
development is it what phase it within
and what's the timeline for it coming
forward
um so we can see those various there
because these Sports pictures School
local Center Etc
foreign
and here again we're setting out the
Quantum of development within
um each of the phases so here we can see
uh uh Parcels one and two 160 homes
Countryside 10 11 and 12 262 homes
bellway
um
that was an application that came to you
more recently
um and then we can see the balance of
716 homes and also details of sports
facilities allotments Etc and the care
home that will again come forward in
subsequent applications
um this slide covers the infrastructure
Reserve matters and again just showing
how it all fits in so we've got phase
one infrastructure which which which
relates to the relief Road here which
was approved in October 2021 under this
application reference
um got a phase two infrastructure
approved
um March 2022 under that reference
number that's the area here adjacent to
the to the Beltway development which
again came to members fairly recently
um we've got current application for
phase three four and five so what we're
dealing with is what fours in this area
here
um and you know elements along the spine
around are joining various other Parcels
um and we can also see where there's you
know future residential phases to come
through
um so which is here
and this drills down into the to the
more detailed infrastructure within the
various phases you know for example the
Maple Road Junction part of the spine
Road Etc relief Road when that's to be
opened
um infrastructure within phase two Etc
um
I'm just going to go through these other
slides fairly quickly because again
they're really just detailed technical
matters but showing you what's the
substance within within the applications
here
so you've got the landscape proposals
again just showing where they fit in
within uh this particular application
and where they are within the overall
scheme of things
again just more detail around the
Landscaping
adjacent's Apostles three four seven six
again where Landscaping goes around for
example heybridge wood
um along Broad Street Green
on the surround the sort of sports area
again these are just matters of details
from US Highways Etc
um this is a spine Road here this way it
comes off the relief Road
again highways General Arrangements
around the sports pitches
um the leaps the northern leap area
Central Loop area
Southern leap area
again matters of detail surface and then
curbing Arrangements
again just details of ditch widening
um
signs and Road markings
based in the sections obviously this is
all part of the attenuation schemes
into some more detail there
playground flood Bond and swell sections
again just around the perimeter of the
playing fields
uh
the Western mammal Crossing
across the relief Road
and just the details there
pumping station General Arrangements
a second just the compound surround of
the pumping station
again just the uh the rigid bus swept
path analysis along the spine Road
so
longitudinal section again just matters
of detail
of the bus shelter along the spine Road
um
another substation
and again just running through those
details again just again just to help
give you the the picture of where this
all fits in but you have in your members
pack
um this slide here
um just sets out some of the
applications which have been approved
um with you already you'll have this
within within your presentation so I
know it's a bit difficult I can
um see something you're probably
streaming to see what it is but um
um again it's just giving more context
and again as a reminder of what this
development is about and and and the
whole General picture
uh you can just see outline master plan
again parameter plans because most a lot
of the assessments is based around how
does the various elements of the scheme
fit in with the parameter plans so we
can see the parameter plans around
um residential density so we're going to
ensure that whatever comes forward to us
fits in with the density that we see is
appropriate or we've approved as
appropriate
um around the various elements of of the
site
the green and blue infrastructure
uh parameter plans around the access and
movement
um
the reserve matters residential I mean
you can see that there's there's three
principal developers on the site
um Countryside
um are provided or providing the major
infrastructure throughout the whole site
uh but we can see we've got the Beltway
development which members considered
recently
we've got the uh Chris Nicholson element
which is in this part here this is
currently you know under pre-application
and will come forward as an application
in due course and the various other
elements got the countryside over here
um
again the phasing and the implementation
which we touched on before
um for example this part of the of the
relief Road
um should be opened and
and operational by the 100th occupation
and this element by the 350th occupation
and just a couple of overhead
photographs just showing the some of the
progress so far you can see the spine
Road there
um the junction of Broad Street Green
and just a wider Vista boat risk
um so that really is again just to give
you give you a context of what the
application is essentially about and how
this proposal sort of fits in with that
um the details are there
um and you would have seen in reading
the report
um all the the consorties uh support the
scheme the details are acceptable
um
what's come forward has been fed again
as I said by a number of uh principal
planning agreement meetings where we've
drill down into the details to ensure
that what comes forward is what is what
the council expects
um and hence the recommendation uh for a
pool of this application as in the
officer's report and subject to the
conditions thank you chairman thank you
very much indeed Mr Johnson but we have
one public participant before we move on
to the recommendation and then debate
um it's the age of Mr Kevin Coleman Mr
Coleman if you like to take a seat at
the table
foreign thank you Tara is it possible to
put that wonderful little two minute
timer up on the board Miss Ford
thank you
perfect
okay Mr common you can see you are two
minutes
um which starts from once you start
talking thank you thank you very much
and good evening and thanks once again
for the opportunity to come along and
and speak to you tonight
um so as you've just heard the
application before you is the third and
final strategic Reserve matters
application covering the key
infrastructure landscaping and open
space really the the the components that
form the framework for the garden suburb
within which the Residential Properties
are then set
um the application follows very much the
same principles that you had on the
previous applications
um this application in particular
includes the remaining part of the
internal tree-lined spine Road and bus
stops it includes three additional play
areas which provide a range of play
equipment for different ages includes
the completion of the network of
pedestrian and cycle routes and it
includes the sports pictures and
allotments
speaking of the allotments as you'll
probably be aware there's now an
agreement in place for the transfer of
these to haybridge Parish Council
and this application is part and parcel
of getting us to the point where we can
then deliver those as as soon as
possible
the sports pitches is an area of ongoing
work where a contractors specialist
contractors being appointed to advise on
the construction of those to make sure
we get the surfacing right and the
drainage right and so on and so forth
and continuing delays with liaise with
your officers about the optimum use and
layout of the pitches
um it's worth noting that the
application includes a full-size
basketball court which was brought in
the request of haybridge Parish Council
you've just seen from the images that
Countryside are making good progress
with delivering the infrastructure
granted under those previous permissions
uh first stage of the relief road is
going in started at the Broad Street
Green Road end as well the internal
spine road is taking shape so the
proposals before you as you've heard
Accord with the parameter plans and the
design code to the same standards as
previously and we hope that you'll be
able to support your officer's
recommendation of approval thank you
very much
I can Mr Coleman and remarkably to the
point thank you well practice Yeah okay
members we have a recommendation
um to approve
um uh subjects the conditions as
detailed in Section 8 of this report
Council stamp um chairman yeah if you'd
allow me to um just speak before you
actually do deliver it I just wanted to
draw members and your attention to a
meeting from performance Governor audit
for July 2022 and in the spirit of
opening it for a debate rather than a
proposal it was recommended that the
chair automatically move in the office's
recommendation prohibits
um the councilors feeling free to be
able to debate it it was a
recommendation and I think it was
approved I can't swear on it but it says
changing the practice of chairs moving
officers recommendation and having it
seconded at the start of the meeting
instead of allowing General discussion
before putting motions Up For Debate
it's up to members if they want to do it
or not but that was the recommendation
made by Paz to this Council so you don't
sort of just close the about it opens at
chairman I think it's a very sensible
approach and that's the approach we'll
take this evening so members I've got
some hands that went up Castle Durham
first of all oh thank you very much
chairman
um
thank you very much Mr Johnson for your
presentation and I think it's very
evident from the very detailed plans
right down to the design of the bus
shelters that we've got far more
information
about the layout and the Landscaping
than we've had for other similar
developments I mean I think if you
compare the information that we've had
here with perhaps South Malden it's
chalk and cheese
um
and indeed it looks very much like from
the road layout and the landscape plans
that this what is going to be delivered
here is much more Akin to the Garden uh
the garden suburb principles that we set
out and unfortunately that that isn't
what we're getting elsewhere in the town
so
um you know clearly we haven't got the
designs of the actual dwellings
themselves yet which will you know
obviously be the defining Point here but
yeah I I think it's a um we've got to a
good place through our consultation with
the developers and through good
um Collegiate working and and yeah I
commend you thank you
thank you Council Durham I think that's
more of a statement there's no question
there so thank you very much indeed
councilor Edwards please
thank you chairman I've got a couple of
observations
um firstly can I look at can you go back
to the um slide with the
parcels
please well that that probably would do
I noticed that the sports pitches
hasn't got a um number although if you
look on the report for
5.2.38 it does mention the various
pictures including a four size basket
pitch
but I was going to ask what other
pictures
uh planned there because I was thinking
particularly of a cricket pitch and I
think that's been muted
um before
and I understand that the
Playing Fields will come through the
approval of the details for the
underclosure one of section 9 of the
section 106. uh
does this application include
discussions on the post pictures or does
that come at a later Reserve application
thank you that's your first question the
second question is
um as always I have concerns or
connectivity to the rest of heybridge
including Pathways and cycleways I know
we can only discuss this application
before us but every application has its
own internal Cycle Way Network without
any connection to the rest of heybridge
and I still have a concern about that
thank you
thank you cancer it was Mr Johnson thank
you
uh thank you thank you thank you
chairman um this application just sets
out the details but it's again it's it's
part of a suite of
um the
um documentation to where which this
this application has to adhere to
um
in terms of the sports element that's
also LinkedIn with the section 106 and
what has to be delivered under that
um
communication has come through and it's
set out within the report
um my apologies I can't remember the
exact section here but it's set out
within the report that Sports England
um have been discussing uh with the
developers with officers about the
development of the sports pitches and
the quickest pictures in particular were
were mentioned
um the the the consultation response um
from from Sports England again as a
summary of those various discussions
um is satisfied that
um with their understanding that the
infrastructure and the sports facilities
will be taken over by the land trust
they will be negotiating discussions
around the delivery of of a cricket
field as part of this proposal I can't
tell you exactly well I can't tell you
where they will go yeah but but that
will be part of the agreement taken
through again what has to be delivered
also under the section 106. thank you
chairman up
sorry you had a second question around
cycleways and connectivity yes chairman
uh connectivity of the rest of habers
not to the rest of the site yeah um
I apologize I I can't comment Beyond add
the connectivity Beyond
um this this site at this moment
um that's not something that I prepared
for on under this particular application
but I'm sure as you know accounts that
we can have a discussion about that
off-site just generally
um
we get that same response from every
application on this site though
um can I just go go back to the um you
say the land trust we're going to be
taken over the sports facilities
there well that's that's my
understanding through the in terms of
the management of it afterwards
I don't know about the detailed
management but um
that's that's through the the discussion
with the with with with with with sports
England
um I mean for example as part of the
communication uh on on this application
um I I can just read this bit for you if
that's okay yeah
um you know to understood that the and
this is from the the planning manager at
sports England
um it is understood that the land trust
has been appointed by the applicant to
manage the infrastructure on the site
including the sports facilities
once they have been completed to the
agreed specification
sport England and the sports governing
bodies that represent the interests of
local sports club would welcome early
engagement with the land trust in due
course to discuss local needs in order
to help ensure that an appropriate
initial plane pitch
layout is provided
Shannon can I just come back on that are
you saying then that that
um
a Cricket Club or a rugby club or a
football club
I used to get in contact with the land
trust to discuss the facilities I can't
comment on the details of that um this
is just a general high-level commentary
in relation to the communication all
right the detailed matters of those
negotiations is not part of this
application and probably wouldn't be
part of something that we as a planning
Authority would get involved with
okay
so um cancer Spencer please thank you
chair
um I Echo um councilor Edward's concerns
as you know I would
um Mr Johnson with regard to the
connectivity and looking at where the
um and I would appreciate a meeting with
you separately with Council Edwards to
discuss because you know the problems
that we've had with other parts of the
suburb and connectivity into the
facilities of the rest of Highbridge
which is affected us as sites developed
it's What's um you know what's connected
to what I have got a couple of questions
um as as you know I'm quite keen on the
ecological aspects of the application
and looking at page 34 at five six seven
five point six point seven Landscaping
will be introduced to retain existing
habitats and to create new habitats now
I may have missed it in this report but
I found
um all kinds of things including songs
Russian Starling
um we've got all the stuff about the
amphibians I'm really curious about the
the the safe Crossing for mammals on the
50 mile an hour relief road but let's
not let's not discuss that that now but
I'm quite I'm quite concerned about the
ground nesting birds and I'm sure it'd
be no surprise to you Mr Johnson's hear
me mention the word skylocks because as
you know you're not surprised we have a
resident who campaigns
um on the existing estate there with
regard to she's not anti-development at
all but she's really worried about the
ground nesting Birds there now it's
unclear to me from looking at this in
the buffer zone around the woods which
is where the skylarks were last nesting
last year when everything was was paid
back whether or not any area there is
going to be
um put aside for them I can't I can't
quite see reference in this unless I've
missed it
um I can't find anything about the
ground nesting birds and I know that um
they're def they definitely were still
there in the last season so can you give
me any more information on that at all
please
thank you chairman
um I'm afraid I can't drill down to that
level of detail
um that level of detail would have been
within the the documentation submitted
with the application and I would have to
say there's a voluminous amount of of
detail you know the you know bumper
documents to be colloquial
um in terms of what what's what's what's
been submitted
um but you know as we can see on under
the statutory consult he's part of the
report you know the the ecology
consultant raises no objection
um and supports them both proposed
mitigation and enhancement measures
through the ecological management plan
um now again you know again these are
quite bumper documents but I mean as you
know counselor obviously we've had
discussions about this I'm quite happy
that again separately because these are
again public documents we can go through
and discuss so that you're fully aware
of the detail and able to obviously
execute your local duties accordingly
good please feel free yeah I'm sure the
new
um climate Action Group there will be
interested in negotiating with the land
trust and people here to make sure that
there is some protection for the ground
nesting Birds there I just quickly
wanted to ask one other question just
because and for members of the public as
well reading this there was a and you
know just your guidance would help so on
page 25 at 4.2.1
um or or 10 actually sorry I should put
my glasses back on shouldn't I the
inspector determining the approved
hybrid application consider that the
need for the reserve matters to be
carried out substantially in accordance
with the design and access statement
it's imprecise and unnecessary therefore
the character areas which is the part
where we've got those character areas
set out in the report set out above or
to be considered as guidance only for
the assessment of the current reserved
matters application I just wonder if you
could give me a little bit of an
explanation of exactly what that means
um
well it's it's
again you know the Devlin is in the
detail in terms of the of these
applications
um the interpretation around
um what the inspector may have said or
any particular condition is is how is
that delivered is you know the applicant
makes their submissions through their
discharge of conditions or through
applications like this
um as I mentioned earlier
um there are there are regular as in
monthly
um
uh PPA meetings with a developer where
we do drill down into in into the
details on this
um and that's where we try to understand
their interpretation of that and if
their interpretation fits with what we
and and our consultees uh with respect
of that that development so it's so to
get to that stage or the interpretation
of that there is all that work behind it
especially on a large scheme like this
which then feeds into this application
it's not just for the applicant to
interpret it as they would think and
submit it because they may do that and
we we we we have that information really
is with our console teams we get their
their responses if it's unacceptable
then they would be told that the
application won't be supported but it's
the but in a scheme like this we work
with the developers and and with a major
scheme and through the ppas that's why
they're so important as part of the
process we drill down and we go into
these detail we make our comments that
they go away and they work on it and
then they come back so it's an ongoing
sort of organic process in the
background
thank you I just think it's important
for members of the public to understand
that so thank you Mr Johnson
I've got one request is for bpas and
acronyms can we actually for the benefit
of people who don't understand those to
actually say what they are please no to
sure thank you thanks very much yeah
because I wouldn't have a clue on half
of them okay
but just to say that when we talk about
ppas we're talking about planning
performance agreements thank you
councilor White please
thank you chairman um yeah mine is
reading all through it
um we've got lots of lovely big
corridors up to 25 meters wide for
Walkers and cyclists and nature
um and I understood after the first
phase that we were going to look into
Bridal ways and surprise surprise there
aren't any
um but and what's interesting is you
you've contacted sport England
um but sport England gave five million
pounds for equestrian this year because
they said that um women are not very
good uptakers of sport but women are big
uptakers of horse riding on the whole
um and I just wondered why you hadn't
bearing in mind all the questions read
before why neither you or the applicants
hadn't looked into that because I think
if we're going to be inclusive and it's
all about being inclusive and making
Sports access for all
um you know and these were green areas
that used to be ridden on and they all
keep getting houses all over them
um yeah we get faster roads busier roads
more traffic horses are getting squeezed
out of everywhere so why why when we've
put this in our plan why won't we put it
in our policies and why when we raise it
every single meeting is it never taken
into account and yet you avoid
everything to do with Broadways there's
every other sort of right of way you can
have
and and prow why haven't you done um
other Pros why is it only footpath and
cycleway in actual fact I think you'll
find a cycle way it should be a
restricted byway which would by its own
definition be open to horses so the
cycle way is it a p r o w as in a
restricted byway or what is it
thank you
I think
thank you thank you chairman um I I do
have to say
um councilor why I I can't answer
um the the sort of substance of um of of
your comments in terms of bridal ways
um
that there are no details of
right-of-ways in this application I
again uh they they yeah the the broad
parameters of application was set when
the outline application was approved
back in 2019
um
no I I appreciate it may have been
mentioned but if it if it hadn't fed its
way through to the detailed conditions
um within within within the outline
application because that would that
would be a that that that would be part
of a broad infrastructure matter and
therefore would have been subject to
um conditions in terms of its delivery
and that hasn't been the case so so at
this particular stage we are well I am
in in in supporting officers with this
application
um
you know we have to follow the
conditions as how it is to go outside of
that I I mean obviously you know a local
Authority can push the boundaries to how
they want but that may not be
sustainable in terms of any appeal
against that if it doesn't fit in with
this with the with the spirit of the
condition as it has been formulated so
that that is a that is a major
constraint
um
that's that's about what I can say at
this stage
did say they were going to make sure
they submitted it back in
2018-19 whenever it was and it's really
disappointing and each time we raise it
and it just shows the applicants have
got no regard to the members because
we've raised it every single time and
then completely ignored it it's just
really disappointing that's all that we
are we're discriminated against as a
minority and a minority sport but
Sportsman we are discriminated against
um and maybe we can look into the form
that the pro is going to take because
it's only a footpath could be a footpath
and a prow for a cycle should come under
a broad
umbrella which should include horses so
perhaps that's something we can look
into okay well thank you as public right
away
Johnson
this there's a condition here that that
talks about public right-of-ways which
is condition I think proposal Roman five
um
but according to legislation a bridal
way
is actually a public right-of-way so I
think the committee has
um you know I think the committee is
right and property to discuss this at
this point and I I do recall this
um but I I always get slightly confused
perhaps Mr Johnson if you can just flick
back through the the slides and
because I'm sure yeah you know I'm not
quite sure but there was one which I
think clearly showed is that the one
that shows the the various developers
that are involved in bringing forward
this area
would be quick to
correct me but I'm sure that one of them
actually included a by the way
on this scheme and someone's nodding no
yes and that got lost see this is this
is why it's very important after these
these meetings to you know to look at
the conditions that the officers have
set but you know we are talking about
byways and from a legal point of view
that does fit within the definition of a
public right way because you can walk on
a bridal way and um and and you can also
drive your animals along one as well
chairman so it's quite an interesting
thing really
traffic which is really what you want
but um but I think we need some clarity
there because I think this has been sort
of lost over
um I don't know if any of my peers have
any more information but I didn't
understand that
um you could be allowed to have anything
else on put parts other than feet you
can't cycle apart so we need to be
really clear on what what
um prow we're having using
foreign
I can just say I've I've noted the point
and and we'll take that take that away
appreciate it thank you very much
councilor heard please
um thank you Jim just just an
observation well a couple of questions
and one observation on page 29
um at five two three five
um it talks about uh leaps and neeps uh
it says that the the nape should have
called with the standards that it should
be within a walking time of 15 minutes
from home and I think a leap should be
within five minutes walking distance
from a well-used pedestrian route but I
wondered why that wasn't uh on there on
the leap because they're supposed to be
local but that's that's not a question
it's just an observation
the other one is on page 32
and this is about uh the uh parking
standards are not set specific standards
for allotments
so
um are we talking about a hard standing
for these vehicles and if we if we are
uh are we still going to see the the
days back when we have these small
thin parking areas that you can't really
get a car in and open the doors so I
wondered my question is why why is it
that the vehicle parking standards does
not set specific minimum parking
standards for allotments
that's my first question the other one
is on with just the next page 33
uh and this talks about
uh the
infiltration drainage and it says that
um
on the second paragraph of five five
three
I think I uh
yeah how um it says that the agreed
drainage strategy
uh
was that due to the relatively shallow
groundwater infiltration drainage
techniques will not be utilized on the
site however other Suds techniques will
be used and these and they go on to say
a mixture of rain water butts permeable
Paving to private driveways swales ponds
and attenuation basins
that seems to be an awful lot of
solutions to a problem that doesn't
appear to exist so I wondered wondered
if that was right
thank you chairman um
well my understanding that it is correct
it's um the for example some of these
areas some of the attenuations they do
double
you know as you know amenity areas for
General use so there's their purpose is
not just to you know collect
um provide the permeability or to direct
um
um rainwater
um you know in times of heavy rainfall
they they they they they have a dual
purpose I mean when it talks about
um
I mean there's there's quite a number of
things they will be
what's appropriate for a particular uh
environment uh say along the roads or uh
adjacent to the
um
playing the plane areas the sports
pitches
um they will vary in terms of the
particular mechanism that will be used
so I suppose while it sounds like a lot
when it's sort of coalesced into a
sentence in terms of how it's uh
distributed and utilizes appropriate
around a quite a large area
um for me and also in terms of the the
lead local flood Authority it's it's an
appropriate approach that the developers
taking
thank you very much thank you very much
sorry and the about the parking parking
standards on the on the allotments
please yeah again
um
well we are we are constrained by the
the the the parking vehicle standards
that Malden has has adopted
um if it doesn't have specific standards
for allotments
um then there's there's no standard we
can apply in in that in that particular
sense an area has been provided
um commensurate to the size of the
allotments
um but the report does uh while I can't
pick it out right here but my
recollection of of that of that set of
that paragraph uh was that
given that allotments aren't used every
day by everyone yeah
um the the area of car parking
um allocated would be appropriate for
you know acceptable parking
application or standards even though
there is no specific standards we're not
going to have an area where it's sort of
crammed out people are going to be there
all night or people can't find them in a
way to park it's all part of their
leisure activities that people will
you know as we know they will use as and
win as as a maybe appropriate I just
have just a supplementary there so does
that also include uh the car parking for
sporting facilities are they also
non-regulated
um I think there is there is there is
regulation for the sporting facilities
based on the area and how much parking
is to be provided
okay so they should be they should be
set to the minimum standards yeah yeah
okay thank you very much councilor Hull
please
and thank you please don't don't please
don't stand it's all right it's fine to
see me then otherwise we know you're
there don't worry
oh I um anyway it's coming back to the
horse ride and it's really good you know
we try to get people fit and you've got
basketball allotments cycleways
footpaths the nature reserves and you
know there's more horses in Essex than
any other County and yet I've I've been
here four years we've only managed to
get one little Bridal way of like a
hundred meters and um and that's been
stopped because the builders have said
oh we'd rather pay the fine than let you
ride up there and and we definitely
definitely asked for bridal way here so
we why are we sitting here week in week
out because I just feel like it's a
waste of time
streams because we don't want
I think it's um it's more of a statement
than a question but I do remember as
well that it has been raised on many of
occasions uh councilor stem please
yeah thank you chairman um today I
actually ask the developer or whoever if
they are on their leaps and leaps it
says they're going to have six pieces of
equipment on a leap and 12 on a neep
um can I ask them if them if they would
be a little bit more adventurous we have
a lot of children with challenges
um and instead of just having the normal
thing when I say springy chicken and a
swing and a little bit of a slide well
they always have springy chickens
they're just disguised as not chickens
but they're very springy so can we
actually look at
um providing because it says quite
clearly if you actually look we do a lot
of work nowadays with with send children
we're trying to get provision into the
area etc etc and and I do really feel
that we need to actually start looking
outside the box instead of having what I
call cheap standard things we could all
have in our garden can we not just have
something which is bigger more
adventurous adapter and caters for
children in wheelchairs you know so they
sit there and they can play with things
on the side eyes or whatever they want a
trampoline that's in the ground whatever
let's use some imagination instead of
saying let's say that this is councilor
Durham was really quite complimentary
about this being what it should be which
is a beautiful area can't we have some
beautiful things in there why does it
always in the prom Mr chairman where you
have a galleon and something big
well sorry cancer fluka but
um well I'm sorry if I was being a
little bit whatever but the point that
I'm making
is oh yeah well whatever this is going
to be with the um with the developer so
can we actually look at it I mean if the
developer wants to look at my phone
afterwards I'll show him some really
good designs of how it can actually fit
into I'm being serious I know I'm a
little bit flippant but I do think we
really do need to look at the needs of
our residents and our young people at
different ages there's two sites on here
a leap and an ape and I think we need to
actually start to do something a little
bit better and not just keep putting a
springer chicken and a slide and a swing
thank you chairman do you have any
comment on that Mr Johnson
the three Valley points
um thank you chairman um I I don't have
any specific comments um obviously
um I'm sure councilor sliders that's
kind of slide
counselor counselor stamp has seen the
slides
I can see why I made the mistake now
um and obviously there is there is a
whole range and I'm sure that your
comments are in context of probably what
you've seen uh on the presentation
detail which does seem to set out a fair
range of equipment
um you know play Boulders I'm sure you
probably would say that doesn't stretch
the imagination too far
um but uh I I can't say at this stage it
maybe I don't know how specific
um these play equipments are they may be
indicative some of them do seem to have
um a sort of number I don't know if it's
like a product number or something but I
don't know how specific they may be for
the for the developer
um you know the the planning agent is
here obviously here in this
um
and it it does seem to me that given
given the variety that's here
um there could be they could be amenable
to to more variety or an exchange of the
type that they've presented here
back chairman that's exactly what I
wanted they said it so the developer can
hear and anybody else will actually be a
little bit more adventurous
um rather than a springy chicken
yeah thank you very much indeed I'll
never look at the springy chicken again
um councilor Swain please yes thank you
chairman
um first of all it's very um pleasing to
see that about 50 of the house is going
to have these Swift bricks in that would
be very interesting too see how that
goes I've got a number of points firstly
on the allotments 20 plots seems very
small very limited even for this
development I I'm I don't know whether
they're going to be more elsewhere but
um that seems very limited as far as the
sports area is concerned is it large
enough to um
Encompass all these different sports or
they is it are they going to be sort of
um taking turn and turn about
re-designing areas and that sort of
thing it seems
um well they no cramp particularly if
you're trying to get a a cricket pitch
in and several other sports
um
on the um Subs
it's been pointed out that the
um the water table is very high
um and I don't know that water pumps is
going to do much
um they're very limited
um uh at which we say Resort
um but if the or sinks the
water table is so high that must mean
that the suds swales and so on
um are quite extensive
um and maybe deep so I
um I do uh what should we say my concern
is that these are really could be rather
sterile areas
um rather than usable
um and um I'm concerned about the
gradient of them if they do have
significant amount of water in them
whether they become a a hazard
um I mean I think we're going to get
these one in a hundred
um plus 40
downpours more frequently than one in a
hundred
um and will the system actually
still be able to
keep the flow off the outflow to the
Greenfield
standard
and on the
environment side
I'd be interested to know what is meant
by the Woodland buffer
um is it just a green strip is it
intended to be in some sense a buffer
between the residential development and
the Woodland
um in other words restricting in some
way rather than just being an expanse
thanks Jim thank you Mr Johnson
thank you chairman um unfortunately I
can't drill down into the level of
detail in terms of for example the
um the the Woodland buffer is it you
know
is it a segregated area is it a
transitional area
um
uh but my understanding is it's not a
segregated area
um it will be an accessible area
um but in terms of how is its detailed
treatment in terms of that
um I I can't comment any further in that
detail
um the the the the infrastructure
including these green spaces will be
subject to management under the the you
know sort of Land Management of the of
the entire estate
um so
my understanding is that in part when
when these are developed
um
um it will be it will be open to the the
Land Management acting in on the
interests of of the residents exactly
how those lands will will be used
um but I mean I I just understand it as
a transitional uh uh treatment
um between the residential and the
established Woodland area
thank you
okay yeah satisfy Council Swain
yes
I don't know if that's that's probably
already in in set in stone so to speak
it is
somehow waiting for sports England to
decide how all these Sports can be
accommodated on the area that's been um
set aside for that purpose
um and well as a follow-up point of will
the
um the management of the trust
management Trust
um include or actually
be controlled by a residents
sorry is your is your question in
relation to the sports facilities or the
general infrastructure
um
because I think there's there's possibly
going to be different layers of
management because we've been talking
about the land trust is largely the
you know the more substantial
infrastructural type parts of the
development so the sort of main areas
rather than maybe more common or more
locally
um managed areas which may be a a local
management company I can't speak too
much about that that's just sort of my
peripheral understanding of how these
things are taken forward but I wouldn't
want anybody to think I'm saying
anything authoritative in that sense
because I you know I can't and it's and
it's far too early in the scheme
um you know for for you know
my understanding of how how that would
be taken forward
um all we know that the the the the main
structures are being set through the
Section 106.
um the land trust as per part of the the
overall agreement
um are taken over the infrastructure
areas which also includes the Woodland
as well
um and it's it's it's how that's going
to be taken forward I mean that that
really sort of is outside of the
planning process that we deal with
obviously will the whole of the
Garden suburb be under the sink one
single Land Trust
for management yep
my understanding that that would be the
case
account suspense that you have a pointer
yeah if I could just help help on that
the land trust is going to manage the
entire of Western Park is my
understanding from having spoken to the
developers at length about that with
with councilor Edwards
um that I don't know about the sports
pitches in terms of who will manage
those eventually but the idea is that
the pitches at the moment will be
interchangeable that's what they're
examining
um the other thing is that when you're
talking about nhgs don't forget that the
suburb itself the North haybridge Garden
suburb isn't just Weston Park there are
two other parts and they are managed by
separate uh management companies so just
to give a little bit of clarity thank
you thank you very much indeed Council
especially councilor Morgan please uh
thank you Mr chairman just trying to
help out to Johnson into the question
issues as far as I'm aware uh you can
cycle down a bridal way but you can't
ride a horse down a cycle there so would
it be too simple just to say right we'll
call them Bridal waves rather than cycle
okay
so it's a very sensible suggestion
foreign
cancel the bill
hey chairman
um I'm looking at the allotments and I
think I think we was told there was ten
I think it's about 10. so on the
assumption that we've got about 4 000
odd properties going to be in haybridge
you've got one in 400 chance of actually
getting an allotment because you're not
allowed even though it's called Malden
haybridge allotment Society moldum will
not allow haybridge residents to
actually use their allotments so that
those 10 or whatever it is is amongst
about one in 400 the allocation also can
um
Mr Johnson please confirm or deny have
we got
um interconnectivity between all these
new houses and haybridge as such
because otherwise you're going to be
going up Broad Street Green
to just get onto this estate or up
Langford road to get onto this estate
I just cannot believe
that with this amount of houses you've
got no connectivity whatsoever and you
know with that Sharps Meadow we had the
same issue
can you show me any of the
links to to existing heybridge
thank you Council Bill Mr Johnson
thank you chairman um I I can't
specifically
um speak in in any detailed way about
the links to
um
you know exist in areas around around
the site
um
I mean I mean when I look at the plan I
can point to for example
um down in this area there's there's a
two-way Arrow which seems to suggest
some level of interlinking but I'm not
familiar with the areas down here to
know what does that mean how does that
translate in on on the ground and
um
that that's something that I would have
to take away for me to come back more
authoritatively I can get an answer to
that but I don't have an answer at this
point
so you're confirming there are links no
no I'm not confirming anything why
I'm not in a position to at this point
in time
but it's something I can tell you're
telling me that those arrows
are supposed to be the connectivity
there was they would seem to suggest but
I I wouldn't I wouldn't I'm not saying
that with any authoritative voice apart
from the fact that it would seem to
suggest some level of two-way I don't
know what that means
so now we're in that planning
application does it mention connectivity
sorry in all of this all of these
applications are coming through is there
any mention whatsoever of
interconnectivity
well you know we haven't got all of the
various Parcels of land that's come
through showing how the the residential
elements
um and their various edges are are going
to be dealt with
um so for example if we're looking at
um you know the Beltway site here
um you know this is at the edge this is
at the corner where they have access to
the relief Road and access directly to
Broad Street Green
um
36 and seven are here is which is
currently under
um uh discussion that pre-applications
day at a yeah pre-application stroke uh
Planet performance agreement when we
sign it stage
um where these are matters which can be
raised but again given where they're
they're located I mean the the edges are
bounded by the site itself in terms of
how it connects otherwise and there are
there all there are other various phases
I think that there's the this drawing
down here talks about future
applications and sort of what what's
what's coming forward uh we have
identified here we've identified here
this area here where we've actually got
the two-way thing these are an
applications that are coming forward
I I don't clearly don't know the detail
of that but again in terms of its
broader context I don't know how it's
set in terms of how it relates to its
edges down here
um I mean these are something that with
these areas that can be considered
um when these matters are bought before
us
come on come back so when is it
considered because I don't want this to
be the same issue as the bridal ways say
oh well you haven't mentioned it or you
should have said it at this point okay I
I can't promise anything at this stage
because again we have the outline
application which is set broad
parameters
so not to be confused with parameter
plans around various constraints so this
this this development
edges are something which if they
haven't
especially if they connect with other
areas and we're talking about change of
land ownership change of detail change
of levels I mean for example some of
these matters are what we've come across
in terms of where this part I can't
remember where it is I remember exactly
where it is
um around here somewhere no it's down
here isn't it
can't remember is that where it is
it's a bit too faint for me to kind of
recognize but
yeah it's sort of yeah it's round here
somewhere yeah up right exactly that
it's round there I mean
that was that was an unresolved uh uh
well it wasn't even considered in any
great detail apart from a vegan
indicative line on the on the
applicant's drawing which terminated at
its boundary
um which has given right to the issues
then and I can recognize that but I
don't know what it means in terms of in
term in terms of the other riches
um is this something that can be
considered at this particular time in
terms of what the developer
can be
requested to do Under the application
these are things I don't know I can only
take these backers consideration so for
me it's useful to hear these points race
to be then taken back and then to sort
of put in a mix when we're considering
but that can be no promise that it can
be delivered until I know the detail
well really neat them to take that on
board because
as we've said there's going to be a
school there
and it's not just going to be the people
living on that estate
that are going to be going to that
school is going to be pet children from
the existing hay bridge at the minute
how would they get there did they have
to go away at Broad Street green or up
Langford Road just to get onto that
development
it's a bit of a nonsense
thank you very much indeed Casa Fleming
I think you've got something to ask
thank you chair just following on from
this for the benefit of members there is
well I think it's a footpath because I
walk on it maybe it's not
um it's I think it's called grapnell's
Farm Chase or Wood Lane maybe yeah so
that goes from Holloway road so that
would go all the way up the sort of bit
of land to the left of the sports
pitches that's not included in this
development but it's it's a farm or
small holding yep so the the there's a
footpath of the the chase runs all the
way up there all the way up to the wood
so that will provide connectivity from
Holloway Road up there I mean it's a
quite bumpy it's not terribly well made
up so and I think it's just footpath
it's not a bridal way it's not a buy way
it's just a footpath but pedestrians can
get from haybridge from Holloway Road up
that footpath well I'm hoping it's
footpath because
okay councilor Darren please
yeah thank you just going back on this I
I mean we we're laboring it a lot but it
is important you know public
right-of-way is exactly that but it has
to go somewhere it's absolutely
pointless to have footpaths and public
rights of way crisscrossing this
development if it doesn't link up with
the wider Network that's that's the
whole point and I'm hoping that those
little arrows are where the internal
footpaths or whatever they are link up
with with the outside I suspect they do
but we can't take it for granted because
Sharps Meadow has been mentioned which
provided internal footways on that
development that were meant to line up
Mr Johnson knows this very well so we
met down there we're meant to join up
with an existing road that the residents
put a fence up because they didn't want
people using it so we need to be on the
ball and we need to make sure that where
these
um footpath links are shown that they
are actually delivered even more so look
it's pointless having a bridal eye on
the site unless it links to a bridal way
you go from on the outside unless you're
going to ride your horse along a road
onto the site and just ride it around a
housing estate that doesn't make doesn't
make sense at all so it needs to be
linking and let them existing Bridal way
rather than just being isolated and then
and for councilor Spencer's
um comfort for the mammal Crossing I'm
assuming it's like the ones on the a130
which is a badger tunnel and underneath
the road rather than across it it's
cheaper than the footway for them
thank you certainly cheaper than the
horse foot way over the railway in
Witham but um there there's about a
dozen Badger tunnels under the a130
which I'm sure it's a yes there they are
that's exactly that's exactly the same
as on the 130. yeah
all children can get through it as well
let's let's hope that that doesn't that
counts the Sean is she please
thank you thank you chairman um I'd just
like just like sort of reinforce a
couple of things they've already been
said this evening so I will be brief but
while the agent is here as as has been
mentioned before
um I'm really pleased about the um Swift
bricks
um you know these Swift brick houses
I've been talking to Developers for
years about this developers and planners
I've been talking about for years I'm
really pleased to see that they are
coming in on this development and in
such numbers as well and I hope that
they
um you know stay on this uh you know
within this text I wouldn't you know
want them to be sort of thrown out at a
later date we really need to keep those
in thank you chairman and also I would
like to reinforce what councilor stamp
has said about the uh play things in
these leaps and leaps or what or
whatever they are there are some really
good player apparatus around made a
really strong metal that will last for
years and years and years and and as
Council stamp said the stuff that's on
the list and that's usually put in these
developments is really old hat
um and and this and the springy things
just drive me nuts I think they are
stupid I really think they are stupid
have no place in a modern play area
thank you chair thank you very much
uh Council Spencer please last time yeah
just just one last thing and and backing
up what uh councilorator was just said
um what councilor Baylor said and
councilor done we do need to to have
meetings on the ground and you know this
Mr Johnson already because the situation
members is for the 10 11 and 12 which we
recently approved is that in truth most
of the people on those Parcels the 262
Homes at the moment because the rest of
the suburb isn't built will be
traversing Broad Street Green on foot
because the other the other entrance
didn't work and still isn't um and
probably won't be because it's part of a
legal dispute so
um you know there is a problem with the
way this was was phased and the
connectivity works so we do really need
to make sure that going forwards we have
the right Connections in place and and
not the meeting to mention it but here I
go I'm going to mention it anyway is
that I do hope that we will get
improvements to Broad Street Green Road
to make it more pedestrian friendly and
I've been thinking about that and
working behind the scenes on that a lot
and I hope it not from this development
but eventually we do because this you
know this this suburb was planned long
before I came along and it is surrounded
by country lanes with very little
pedestrian access and we should be
moving away from that and I hope that
things can be rectified so that it will
be better for residents in the fullness
of time thank you thank you very much
please yeah thank you chairman I mean
Kevin I don't think we should lose sight
the fact that we're dealing with the
reserve matters application here and and
whilst I take a certain degree of
comfort in what
um Mr Johnson said
um yeah we have had problems in the past
we've agreed to things like prior to
waves asked it to be conditioned and
then it hasn't been conditioned but
that's as much as the fault of the
members of anybody else for not reading
the reports after the meetings but
chairman you know I hear the discussions
about connectivity
5.2.26 I think it is deals with
connectivity through the the site I
think they refer to it as a green space
code so that shows you if you read that
narrative it shows it tells you how it
connects to other things
um highways don't have any objections to
this
um you know I as far as by the ways are
concerned I mean come to South Minster
you know Woodside 106 agreement we had
to buy the way through there and I'm
sorry that it's not using but you're
most welcome to come to the parish and
use it
um and then chairman you know as far as
I'm concerned with this you know we
we've discussed it long and hard
um and I can't really see all the
statutory Consultants support it there's
no objections from the parish council
and and I think that from what the
members have said I haven't heard them
say anything really that speaks to
refusing this application so Gemini
would propose I would propose chairman
that we agreed the recommendation thank
you second
so before we actually I moved to that um
because I heard is the last speaker on
my list so I would like to go to council
heard first and then move your
recommendation accounts of Luca
you need to turn your microphones
it was really just uh just to help Mr
Johnson perhaps on five two three two it
talks about uh a green Corridor and uh
goes on talking about footpaths
connecting the largest site of the North
haybridge Garden suburb with the s2e I
don't know what s2e is though
yeah please feel free
cancel the Army microphones
sorry thank you
thank you okay thank you Council so we
have um uh Council fluka
um making a recommendation which was
second did
um sorry my screen's gone there by Casa
Durham
um so members do you want to agree this
bison or would you like a recorded Vote
or agreed agreed by consent thank you
members that's carried
very much we move on to item number six
which is application two two zero one
zero two four slash o u t outlying Land
north of man gaps Railways Museum South
Mr Road Burnham on Crouch Essex we had a
members update issue to us
um and the members update says it's been
redrawn for committee uh for for reasons
uh interrupture and say point of order
thankless you can chairman I'm I'm
fearful of where this where this debate
may go and I would propose chairman that
we either do it we either discuss what
you've just proposed as an emergency
item rather than open up the planning
application which is what you you're
planning to do uh or better still
chairman
um take the the committee into private
and confidential under section 100a of
the ACT thank you
um let me just say hang on a second
chance
I mean
yeah
yeah well I think Council as Council
stamp has made a a question earlier on
in Open Session I'll allow councilor
stamp to ask a question
um and then if if the debate comes on we
may move that into private confidential
session
German I don't want to debate it I don't
think it's appropriate to debate it I
just actually want an explanation of
what it actually means
yep thank you fine thank you I also I'd
like to Second cancer stamp because um
if we can just be um a little bit more
detailed in the explanation of why it
was withdrawn that would that would help
members
thank you chairman as I said there's
very little I can say uh but probably
just to put a few more words around
um what's in the members object
um
this um matters has come to my attention
um quite well
quite recently
um within this week in terms of
um Consulting responses
um and
um that the Consulting responses were
inconsistent with the status of the
application
but what had happened during the
application it was initially submitted
as uh well an outline for Access and
layout
um for future considerations as a
standard but during that process it was
amended to remove layout
uh from the consideration so that if it
was only access
however a number of the Consulting
responses didn't have regard to the fact
that layout had been removed so that's
so that significantly impacted on how
the assessment was taken forward so
that's that's the sub that's the
substance of so it would members would
have had in front of them information
which actually wasn't accurate in terms
of the nature of the application in
front of them thank you Mr Johnson I'd
like to thank Mr Johnson because I
actually did a lot of research on
outline and what should be included and
I'd gotten three three paragraphs ready
to read out anything that was going to
be said at this meeting tonight because
it's really important that the
information that is provided is actually
dealt with on the application so thank
you very much for the clarity yeah thank
you thank you Mr Johnson Echo there from
the chair but it'll also be making a
recommendation over in scrutiny about
this issue uh members uh any other
urgent members of business that the
chairman decides are Urgent I have none
so therefore members I'd like to close
this meeting at uh 2047 and thank you
for your contributions please travel
home safely and enjoy your evening thank
you meeting closed